people go how can you listen to problems
all day long that's quite frankly not
what i do i get people
better i get their brains better their
minds better their relationships better
what are your thoughts about tom
cruise's assessment on medicine not
being the solution
to helping people's psychological issues
i think how psychiatry is currently
practiced
is just a scandal and it's a mess 85
of psychiatric drugs are prescribed by
non-psychiatric physicians
in 10-minute office visits is it true
that the brain's a muscle that the more
you work it the stronger it gets
or that's just the myth ultimately it's
responsible
for your success relationships work
money joy happiness the epidemic
of teenage suicide is being driven by
social media as girls
constantly compare themselves in a
negative way
then you struggle more with anxiety
depression trauma or grief
[Music]
my guest today is an expert in an area
many of us need help with specifically
your interviewer
myself yours truly he's a 13-time new
york times bestseller
he has scanned 175
000 brains that he has access to his
facility that he runs from 155 different
countries
he's a double board certified child and
adult
psychiatrist and many other things i can
say about this man
on the great work he's done he's got
tens of millions of views on youtube in
the area of
expertise brains with that being said my
guest today
dr daniel amen doc thank you so much for
being a guest on valuetainment
well thank you so much for having me and
helping me
spread the word about brain health one
of the things i like the fact
is our interview that we started on time
and we had no technical difficulties so
i love the fact that
you know it allows us to have more time
together so i appreciate your patience
while we were going through the madness
with zoom earlier but
good to have you on um you know you you
hear stories
and you'll say you know you watch a kid
and you say why did you end up becoming
a cop my dad was a cop why did you end
up going in the military
and serving 20 years and becoming an
officer like when i talked to general
mcchrystal well because my dad was a
general my
grandpa was in you know and colonel and
this one okay got it that makes sense
there's a lineage you want to go out and
follow the footsteps yes
why did you want to be a brain surgeon
with you with your background how did it
lead to you doing what you're doing
today
um well actually i was the first one in
my family to graduate from college so
i am the son my grandparents immigrated
from the middle east
and my dad clearly smart enough to go to
college but
just worked like crazy from the time he
was 12.
and uh when i was 18 the
vietnam was still going on and i became
an infantry medic
that's where my love of medicine was
born
but about a year into it i realized i
didn't really like being
shot at it wasn't my thing some people
like it for me i'm like no people could
get hurt out here
and i became an x-ray technician and
developed a
passion for medical imaging as our
professors used to say
how do you know unless you look and then
i got out of the army and went to
medical school
and when i was a second year medical
student someone i
loved tried to kill herself and i took
her to see a wonderful
psychiatrist and i came to realize if he
helped her it wouldn't just help her
that ultimately it would help her
children and
even her grandchildren as they would be
shaped
by someone who is happier and more
stable so in 1979
i fell in love with psychiatry because i
realized it could change generations
people but i fell in love with the only
medical specialty that virtually
never looks at the organ it treats
and i knew it was wrong and i knew it
would change
i just had no idea i'd be part of
the change and in the late 1980s
i was an army psychiatrist i trained at
the walter reed
army medical center washington dc in the
late 1980s i started looking at the
brain
and it just changed everything
i do you know i don't really think of
myself as a psychiatrist
i think of myself as a brain health
specialist
a clinical neuroscientist where my
whole job is to get your brain right
and i want to make brain health cool
because quite frankly nobody really
wants to see a psychiatrist
when i told my dad i wanted to be a
psychiatrist he asked me why i didn't
want to be a real doctor
why i be a nut doctor and hang out with
nuts all day long so my dad never got
father of the year award um
even though he was a good guy but he
just didn't you know
like was he being sarcastic or he was
being really like serious with you like
why are you
he was dead serious mad at me
you know what am i going to tell my
friends yeah sons
shrink and you know he hangs out with
nuts all day long
and even though that hurt my feelings
i totally get where he was coming
because most psychiatrists don't act
like real doctors
um they don't look at the organ they
treat
and when i started looking it just
changed my whole life
in such a good way so did your patients
ever make you go nuts or no
well i've treated it came public last
year that justin bieber has been one of
my patients
and that was close
yeah no we've taken care of some just
wonderful
but complicated people and
you know people go how can you listen to
problems all day long
and that's quite frankly not what i do i
get people
better i get their brains better their
minds better their relationships better
their spiritual selves better which is
sort of an odd thing to say for a
psychiatrist
but when you get when you help people
get better
it's thrilling it's exciting i have
loved it
every day for 40 years you know the only
reason i asked that question is because
i have friends who are detectives or
cops or you know
divorce attorneys or dea agents and you
know
i was former military so you got delta
and all these guys and you're taught to
be a little bit paranoid you know so
when they come home
it kind of bleeds into their marital
life you know what were you doing what's
going on who's this song yeah they're
very extra
paranoid so when you're a psychiatrist
and you hear a lot of people's issues
it it literally filters out of you
nothing sticks where you kind of catch
yourself when you come home at night
you're
irritated you're upset you're frustrated
or kind of reacting to a patient's
conversation you had earlier
not really i mean you know i help them
manage their minds and in the process
whenever you help someone
do something you tend to be better at it
yourself i agree and um
and i work with my wife so we have done
over a thousand brand warriors way
podcasts we just finished filming our
fourth
national public television special she's
my best friend i mean you know we had to
figure out how to work together
but we had someone a consultant once
said
look at him like you love him
that just helps so much and so we're
always
thinking about how to have better minds
and better brains and it
leaks over to the kids very
how you guys been together 15 years
15 years very cool so okay so let's put
that part aside let's go to the next
part of it here
um you know i like bodybuilding i follow
a lot of athletes a lot of bodybuilders
we've had a lot of bodybuilders we've
interviewed here
and you know when somebody builds their
biceps you can see it when somebody
builds their chest you can see it when
somebody works on their abs you can see
it there's a
you know visible you kind of look at and
say look you look good your abs look
good you know your traps look good
you know you hear the saying a brain
is a muscle you know your brain's like a
muscle the more you feed it the more you
know it could get this
you know more you read the more you
learn is it true that the brain's a
muscle that the more you work it the
stronger it gets
or that's just the myth the more you use
it
the more you can use it so
the brain is very much a use it or lose
it
organ that when you learn something new
your brain makes a new connection when
you stop
learning your brain actually starts to
disconnect
itself and makes it harder
for you to learn that's why adults when
they go back
to college the first semester or two
they're
really struggling because they're not
used to it
but over time you have this great part
of your brain called the hippocampus
it's on the inside of your temporal
lobes and it's
greek for seahorse because it's shaped
like
a seahorse and every day
you make new stem cells
in the hippocampus so i just
think of it like every day
you're making 700 new baby seahorses
and your habits are either growing
them or murdering them
i had a fun conversation with miley
cyrus
who came out last year as one of my
patients and
she she was smoking pot and drinking and
not doing the right things
and i told her about the baby seahorses
and she goes that's so unfair you know
i'm an
animal lover and i never want to do it
and she's just doing such a better job
of taking care of her seahorses
um and they're things we do every day
that either
grow our brains or shrivel
our brains and because most people never
look at the brain
most people never care and that's
what we need to make cool caring
about your brain because ultimately
it's responsible for your success
relationships work money
joy happiness there's an organ
called the brain that is responsible for
all of that can you unpack that well
when your brain works right you work
right
your brain is the organ of decision
making and i
argue your level of success in life
is basically a sum of all the decisions
that you've made and when your brain is
healthy
you're more thoughtful you have better
control
over your impulses you're more organized
you
are better at planning and then acting
in ways
consistent with your goals and
most people are never thinking you know
that if i
drink too much alcohol or smoke pot or
eat bad food that it's actually going to
negatively impact the moment by moment
decisions
that i make this is really important
stuff
that when your brain works right you
work right and when it's
troubled for whatever reason you played
football in high school like i did
or you hit soccer balls with your head
or you were in that
jeep accident when you were in the
military
damage the brain damage your decisions
damage your life
so does it mean elon musk's brain
looks like arnold schwarzenegger in his
20s
that's a great analogy that
uh you know he's so smart and has
learned
so many diverse things and that's what's
really good for the brain
it's not doing the same thing over and
over again
it's this having this level of diversity
that means his brain is likely
very unique and working hard
who is have you like i'm curious right
now when you scan
a brain i mean you got 170 thousand but
when you scan a brain
can you tell apart a brain of someone
who is
got a high iq genius a great decision
maker versus somebody that hasn't put it
to use a lot and doesn't read a lot it's
just kind of you know
living a regular life can you see it
through skin or that's not something you
can see through skin
well we can clearly see how healthy your
brain is
the healthier it is the brighter you are
generally
we can see tendencies in the brain are
you
spontaneous which means you don't like
waiting in line
and you're very creative but you can't
focus unless you're super interested
are you persistent um it's sort of
another way of calling someone a jerk
it's they're worried rigid and flexible
if things don't go their way they get
upset
argumentative oppositional we can tell
if they're more sensitive
more tendency to be empathic
or more cautious where they tend to be
more anxious so the scans give us a lot
of information
so basically is it healthy is it sleepy
does it tend to work too hard has it
been
hurt like traumatic brain injury david's
like a major cause of psychiatric
problems
and nobody knows about it because most
psychiatrists never look at the brain
we can tell if you've had toxic exposure
i have dozens now of covid19 brains
and it's very interesting when it
impacts your brain it doesn't always but
when it does it tends to
fire up your emotional brain so the
dragons that i write about
in my new book your brain is always
listening um
it tends to fire them up and you
struggle more with anxiety
depression trauma or grief
so okay so that's uh that's interesting
because
i'm assuming if you went through the
school that you went through to become a
psychiatrist and you've scanned 170 000
did you when you were going through
school have a chance to see
the scan of an einstein like did they
have a scan of some of the smartest
people in the world for you to say look
at einstein's brain here
was there any kind of you know classes
you took where you were able to see the
scan of some of the most genius brains
of all time
genius minds of all time well i've
certainly been able to do that i mean
we've scanned
incredible athletes hall of fame
athletes
and we've scanned pulitzer prize-winning
writers and
the interesting commonality
is their cerebellum works really well
cerebellum is in the back bottom part of
the brain
it's latin for little brain and it's
what i think of almost is the central
processing unit
in the brain has half the brain's
neurons even though it's only
10 of the brain's volume that when your
cerebellum
is healthy you process faster which
means you generally think faster
so did you did you guys get a chance to
look at the scans of some of the
brightest brains were you able to kind
of look at it and see any similarities
or no
i'm talking people in the past you know
einstein's
flights like that einstein actually had
a little bit smaller brain
than by weight but his
parietal loads top back part of the
brain
one of the association areas in the
um was had more cells
there it was pretty interesting um
but but as a rule that's not why people
come to see me
okay no i i understand i'm just curious
when you i'm trying to see a trend with
175 000 scans if you see anything there
so
we are living in a pretty vain
era yeah i lived in l.a for 24 years and
cosmetic surgery was just something that
everybody was doing i went to dallas
and dallas's highland park is listen if
you want to do anything cosmetic it's a
great place to be
i'm in boca now and you know boca you
walk around you know everybody's got a
some kind of cosmetic surgery they've
done is there any kind of a
surgeries that can be done to make
somebody
sharper you know a
better process or better decision makers
or anything to be done with that
well there's a lot of things to do not
surgery um
okay you know when they did pre-frontal
lobotomies to try and treat mental
illness it didn't turn out really well
they are doing some specific highly
targeted psychosurgeries for example if
you have ocd
or you have tourette syndrome
you want to be smarter you want a
healthier prettier brain and i love your
analogy
you know i live in newport beach where
there's more plastic surgeons per capita
than
almost any place in the world and i
often say
we care more about our faces our boobs
our bellies and our butts than we do
our brain which is sort of insane
and when i started looking at the brain
i'm like okay how do you make it better
so diet exercise that helps
certain nutraceuticals like i'm a huge
fan of genko
the prettiest brains i've ever seen take
ginkgo ginkgo increases blood flow
to the brain i'm a huge fan of
the persian spice saffron
saffron has been shown in 21 randomized
controlled trials
to be as effective as antidepressant
medications wow saffron wow i take
saffron
every day and there's another treatment
i like a lot called hyperbaric oxygen
therapy where you go into a hyperbaric
chamber
it's been shown to increase stem cell
production so those babies sea horses
and increase blood flow to the brain
i did the big nfl study sort of when the
nfl was not telling the truth about
dramatic brain injury football and
like let's stop lying about this this is
a brain damaging
sport um but 80 percent of my players
get better
when we put them on a rehabilitation
program
multiple vitamin fish oil a brain boost
i created
and many of them also hyperbaric oxygen
therapy when you do that when you
put the brain in a healing environment
it can be
prettier can be healthier which means
you're happier and you make better
decisions
so cosmetic surgery or surgery period to
make somebody become a better process or
better decision maker we're not there
yet
but certain you know dietary
supplements or approach can help you
become a better processor and a better
decision maker
okay um outside of dietary you know in
bodybuilding they say it's cardio
they say it's weightlifting proper
weightlifting
you got diet and then you got as you get
older stretching to make your
muscle more you know a
full makes it look better if you've got
some you see a lot of bodybuilders go
end up taking ballet and gymnastics
because the body comes out
a lot nicer what what is a good
combination you would say to make
someone's brain sharper
so so many of those things and because
the stronger you are
as you age the less likely you are to
get alzheimer's
disease um cardio is
important i tell people walk like you're
late
that it's easier on your joints and
people who walk like they're late
45 minutes four to five times a week
have a lower incidence of cognitive
problems and
depression and so if you're 80 years old
and you can walk three miles an hour
you have a 90 chance of living till
you're 90.
if you can only walk a mile an hour you
have a 90
chance you are not going to live until
wow
90. so exercise diet is
so important your brain is only 2
of your body's weight about 3 pounds it
uses
20 to 30 percent of the calories
you consume think about that so
it is the beverly hills if you will
it's the most expensive real estate
in your body and if you have a fast food
diet
you're going to have a fast food mind
you're more likely to be depressed
and demented no diet is critical
there is a linear correlation between
the number of fruits and vegetables you
eat a day
and your level of happiness up to
eight so eight should be the target for
everyone
um and then nutrients i think are really
important i think
everybody should take a multiple vitamin
everybody should take
an omega-3 fatty acid fish oil
supplement
97 of the population is low
in omega-3 fatty acids critical
for getting your brain to connect right
and to think right and then new
learning needs to be part of everything
you do because when you work your brain
it makes new connections and don't be
overweight right if i had to say
one thing if you say hey daniel what's
the one thing
in my books i talk about bright minds
which is the mnemonic i created to keep
your brain healthy
you want to keep your brain healthy or
rescue it if it's headed to the dark
place
you have to prevent or treat the 11
major risk factors that steal
your mind and the mnemonic is bright
mind so b is for blood flow
r is retirement and aging the d is
diabetes if you are overweight
or have high blood sugar shrinks your
brain
but being overweight actually if you're
overweight you have
five of the 11 risk factors because the
fat on your belly so that's one risk
factor
decreases blood flow i published a study
last year
on 35 000 scans that showed
as your weight went up
the function of your brain went down
what is the correlation between the two
is it energy like i'm just too tired to
want to process and go extend
five more minutes to make a better
decision what is the link
so lowers blood flow to your brain
it increases inflammation
uh because the fat cells produce
something called inflammatory cytokines
that damage
your brain it takes healthy testosterone
and turns it into unhealthy
cancer-promoting forms of estrogen
and it stores toxins and so it does
all of these bad things which means
you really should have an idea of how
many calories
you eat a day i think of calories like
money
and we want to be a value spender
and then the quality of your calories
actually
matters more than the number itself
but there's this fascinating study from
the mayo clinic
where they looked at people who had a
fat based diet
avocados nuts and seeds healthy oils
healthy fish
42 less risk of getting alzheimer's
disease
and they compared them to people at a
carbohydrate-based diet
simple carbohydrate-based diet bread
pasta potatoes
rice fruit juice sugar
a 400 increased risk
of getting alzheimer's disease it's the
sugar
now i'm a fan of carbs just not the ones
that quickly turn to sugar
simple carbs like bread pasta potatoes
rice
and sugar so so the follow-up on this
would be
how much of it has to do with what i see
what i hear so what i see
what i hear what i speak meaning
uh i listen to music is it is certain
kind of music strengthening my
brain because i have to listen to the
words and i have to process what's being
said
it you know gets my creative juice
flowing is it watching if i watch a
exorcist a movie messes with my head
versus watching something that's getting
me to think about the decision making is
it video games
there are a lot of people right now that
are saying certain games make you
smarter as a teaching
if i speak to an audience and i'm having
a debate and a dialogue is that making
me a better processor
a sharper mind what would you say those
four behaviors have to do with us
becoming sharper
well in my new book your brain is always
listening that's sort of the point of
the whole book
your brain is always listening
it's listening to the dragons from the
past those are the big emotional issues
people struggle with
like grief and loss or wounded dragons
it's that they them and other dragons
you're always listening
to the other people alive and dead
like i always have my dad's voice in my
head even though he died a year ago
um it's the sibling and birth order
dragons i don't know how many siblings
you have i have seven
i come from a good lebanese catholic
family respect
and i have five sisters so your birth
order really does
matter you're sort of always listening
are you special
or are you not special
your brain is always listening to your
habits
uh there's a whole section on bad habit
dragons
like people who say yes yes yes when
they should say i have to think about it
or you know the other people like my dad
no no no
it's like the first response is no they
don't even think about it
there's the addicted dragons so whatever
you
allow your brain to do if it's rewarding
it's going to do it again which is why
porn can be
a problem it's why um caffeine and
nicotine and alcohol
and marijuana can be habit-forming
because your brain's
always listening it's like oh i got
rewarded for that let me do
that again um and it's listening to the
scheming
dragons which is
the digital dragons you know the
um netflix documentary social dilemma
emma was so
good yeah and so disturbing because
these
did you agree with it were you were you
in agreement with it absolutely
okay and i've seen it that they're
changing
our brains to make money for their
advertisers
that they're finding what hooks us
and feeding it to us over and over again
i'm
very worried about it because
the epidemic of teenage suicide i
believe is being driven by social media
as girls constantly compare themselves
in a negative way
to the social influencers that
are struggling just like they are i know
i've treated many of them
and so your brain is always
listening to um the food pushers the
toxin
pushers it's always listening to the
news mongers
where the news is actually not the news
anymore
they pick whatever thing is going to get
you upset
and then they play it over and over
again
and people who start their day with the
news
or 27 less happy
as the day goes on i actually have an
app called the good news network
and that's how i start my day i it's
always there's something fun i have an
old friend that wanted to start a
company called gnn
so you did it good news network
i like it i log on every morning
i love it i love it very cool so uh
books
books are there books that don't do
nothing to your brain where it's wasted
like if i read
i don't know if i read 50 shades of gray
versus psycho cybernetics
okay you know and i'm sure you know both
of them with maxwell mull
you know being in your world you
probably read psycho-cybernetics
is there is there books that i feed my
mind that's tapping into
a certain muscle or it's just period
you're tapping into muscle the more you
read and the more you feed your
imagination mind i think what you read
really
matters if you're reading a lot of
horror
stuff just to keep you up and get
excited
that's going to wear out the pleasure
centers in your brain i mean you should
read
for pleasure um like
um pillars of the earth by ken follett's
one of my favorite all-time
books or the da vinci code because it
entertains you
and educates you at the same time
and we need our breakfast to go offline
uh
so that you're not always working um
but at the same time if you're feeding
that garbage
um it's not good for it you can actually
wear out the pleasure centers
in your brain by what you allow your
brain to be
what does that mean so in your brain you
have this area called the nucleus
accumbens and it's really important
because it responds
to the neurotransmitter dopamine and
dopamine
helps you focus makes you happy drives
motivation
and but if you dump dopamine
you engage in behaviors that
cause too much of it to be released
think cocaine
or compulsive gambling or porn or
incredibly delicious desserts you know
high fat
high silver desserts it dumps dopamine
over time if you do it too much or too
often
it wears out the nucleus accumbens
and then it takes more and more to feel
anything at all which is why for my
young superstars
my prayer for them is dear god please
don't let me be famous
before my brain is finished development
which is not until 25 or 26
and so you see these young superstars
like miley and
justin severe drug abuse and it wasn't
drug abuse to feel high
it was drug abuse to chase feeling
normal and wait drug abuse not even to
escape
drug abuse to chase feeling normal right
because their pleasure centers had been
damaged
by the thing so the more famous
you are initially it's awesome it's
unbelievable
it's great when people cheer for you but
dopamine is really the molecule
of more it's a trap because whenever
you get some and it makes you happy
it's not enough and you're going to want
more and more
to get the same reaction so i've had 12
new york times best sellers and one of
them was a best seller
for 40 weeks i mean it was pretty cool
change your brain change your life
but if the next one's only a bestseller
for 12 weeks
which is sort of a historic
accomplishment it's like well it's not
good enough
and so you really have to do work on
your mind
to not let success
steal your happiness when they ask
people who are wealthy what would it
take so people had five million dollars
10 million dollars a hundred million
dollars
what would it take for you to be
perfectly happy
they all said two to three times more
which is sort of ridiculous right i mean
at some point
there's no correlation between money and
happiness
over 75 000 which i think is pretty
interesting
um that we need to really work on our
minds
as much as we're working on our
businesses how do you deal with that how
do you deal with
i mean you've got fame and you you know
175 000 scans these are data these are
bragging rights right
13 times 12 times new york times best
bestseller 40 weeks on the charts
how do you deal with it yourself to not
become
a fiend for more of it or is there
anything wrong with that because if
you i think you said somewhere you like
enjoy watching football i think you said
you like enjoy watching football so i
don't know
if you are you a sports fan yourself are
you a guy dude
i'm a los angeles lakers fan okay you
and i both i'm a die-hard laker fan as
well i'm
interviewed kobe we've had kobe at our
event last year with president bush the
late kobe bryant and
from the day i came to a lot with a
laker fan so
what do we do with the people we admire
so much who are
all about the more sixth championships
jordan back to back to back did it twice
you know kobe got five of them and after
shaq got his fourth before kobe got his
fourth and they had a song about him so
kobe got pissed off when he got his
fifth i said
in the interview he says i think five is
more than four please let make sure shaq
knows this
so is that a bad thing that there is
this competitive juice that produces
into us to say
damn it i want one more than this other
guy named shaq i want to get five you
know what i'm tom brady
everybody says that guy's the mj of
doctors that guy's the mj of
psychiatrist i want people to say that
guy is the brady of psychiatrist that
guy is the brady of
whatever what's wrong with wanting to
compete and do more
well because it's a trap that it's
constantly
going to make you unhappy now i want to
be
the best i can be and i want my books
to be the best they can be but
whenever i argue against reality
welcome to hell and
it's just so important it's really worth
writing down
is i need to be happy with the best
i can do i want to be the best
but if it doesn't work like i hope if
that season i don't
win the championship i'm not shooting
myself
i'm just gonna go of course what can i
do
yeah better and live in the moment
because it's not the destination that
makes anybody happy
because the destination is death it's
one of the dragons
the death dragon it's what i
start every day with today is going to
be a great day
and i end every day with what went well
today i put myself to bed with that
exercise and i even look for the
smallest moments the micro
moments on you know what's the smallest
thing that happened
you know i live in newport beach and i
can see the water from my house
the sunset last night was spectacular
wow
and i see those you know maybe 150
nights a year
but to just take time to appreciate it
or my assistant made me this banana
fresh banana strawberry tea
and it just tastes awesome so it's
really
noticing the micro moments and you know
i've done
big things in my life but it's really
the little things that make me happy
and if i can celebrate being
part of someone else's success
then it's not all about me when it's all
about me
i'm not happy when it's about us
and that's why you know i dearly wish i
could have had kobe and shaq together
because they could have won three or
four more
championships if they didn't have the
psychological nonsense
between them i'm surprised phil wasn't
able to fix that because he was a
psychological guy he was
in another life he could have been a
psychiatrist a hippie psychiatrist but
the guy was an expert
in personalities no the only reason i
say this is because
when i was coming up as a young kid as a
young guy in business i was 21 years old
i just got out of the army
and i was conflicted i was going in the
direction you know
just a rebel so i stopped i met an old
friend of mine we started going to bible
study together on fridays and
we stayed up till two o'clock in the
morning i started reading i know you did
some stuff with rick warren
and i said you know i don't know
you know i went to like 27 churches i
went everywhere i went to scientology i
went to lds i went to jehovah i went to
seventh day i went to
if i could find a religion i went to it
right and
you'd hear well you know competition's
not good and you know you got to be
careful with this and all this other
stuff i'm like
okay and then a lot of these folks who
were saying it
were at the same time some of the most
successful pastors in the world
i'm like wait a minute you're running a
church massive
you you in sports would have been one of
the most
ridiculous competitors look how much
good you've done in the world i consider
rick warren very competitive
the guy's book sold 40 million copies 50
million copies and
he was able to make a big impact so the
only reason i say that is because
sometimes
younger generation when they hear that
message
they devalue that additional effort to
put in to find out what their best
version looks like so that's the only
reason i brought it up because
someone like you with the amount of
accomplishments you had what if you
would have stopped 20 years ago
i wouldn't people wouldn't have you in
your life miley wouldn't have had you in
their lives
i wouldn't have been happy because i
love what i
do and i've had people try to buy
amen clinics and you know i'd get a lot
of money and they
i would be working for them i'm like no
i wouldn't be happy
with that it's not money that for me at
least
and and pastor warren says money is only
something you
borrow because as soon as you're dead
it's somebody else's
and so when you think of it like that
it's the lives change
but but the bible at least for me
doesn't go against success the verse the
parable
i hold on to is the parable of the
talents
that the master gave we just talked
about it today
you know three different people three
different
levels of investment and the master got
mad when
the one person buried his investment out
of
fear and i feel like i've been given
certain gifts and part of it i've worked
really hard
but but i have certain gifts like how to
make complex
information accessible and easy to
understand
and i'm expected to do something
with what i have been given and it's
not just about me
it's about we the whole love your
neighbor as yourself
you're not going to be a very good lover
if you don't like yourself
so yeah i feel incredibly
blessed because i spend a lot of time
working
in the meaning and purpose circle you
know i always think of people in four
big circles what's the biology
what's the psychology what's the social
circle and what's the spiritual circle
which sounds like you've spent time
working there as well
it's so why do i care why am i on the
planet
what is my sense of meaning and purpose
and i need with my patience to always
work in those four circles let's get
your brain right
your mind right don't believe every
stupid thing you think
tame the dragons relationships
right and i'm blessed because i'm
married to my best friend
i was married for 20 years to someone
who didn't really like me very much
and it was just chronic unhappiness and
conflict
that was chronically stressful for me
and now that i'm in the right
relationship
it brings so much joy and so i often
think am i in a good relationship
with my wife am i in a good relationship
with food i only want to love food that
loves me back
am i a good relationship with work am i
doing things
that have meaning and purpose but yet
still can support my family
i love them we're on the same page you
say july 17th right say july 17th or
july 19th july 19th got it i love that
you know
rick warren's book i think came out in
0.203 i mean when i read it i didn't
read it in 40 days i read it in two days
it changed my life when i read rick
warren's book i needed to read a book
like that at that time and
uh uh what was billy graham had an event
november
17th there was four days he came to talk
at in 2003
at uh the rose bowl and i said if he's
speaking i'm speaking i went
wednesday i went thursday friday
saturday half a day and a sunday all day
and pastor rick warren was one of the
guys i gave a message there i'm like
you know uh uh it was seeing a guy
that baptized 210 million people you
have to be a big thinker to be able to
baptize
to go to korea and you speak one and a
half million people show up and that's
what he did
i mean that's just out of control impact
positive impact being made in the world
but
let me wrap up with this before we
finish up here i want to talk to you
about tom sit down with matt lauer
i'm sure you know which one i'm talking
about when
he and matt had a conversation together
let me pull this up i know i'm getting
the zoom thing a little bit mixed up
here okay we got it back here
um have you seen that interview between
the two of them
i'm almost certain you have about how he
knows about psychiatry and
yeah he's a scientologist
and the founder of scientology ron l
hubbard
um was very psychologically minded
and the psychiatric community rejected
him
and and they've rejected me in large
part so i sort of get
how that feels um
and they've sort of been at war with
each other you know
scientologists will rent huge
semi-bands and on the side of them go
psychiatry kills children
and i'm like that sort of hurt my
feelings uh
because i help children but
um you know whenever you have a position
on anything
somebody's gonna hate you and you just
have to be
clear within yourself on what you know
is right and stay with it
and i want to read it to you i want to
read it to you because i want to see
i think there's some some alignment
between the two of you guys
but i'm just curious to i'll i'll read
you two parts of it
so the whole thing was about the story
with i think brook shields right and she
says uh you know uh uh i've never agreed
with psychiat psychiatry ever before i
was a scientologist i never agree with
psychiatric okay so that's that's kind
of your space what he's saying matlab
comes back and says
but if there's a particular thing that
makes her feel better
whether it was antidepressants or going
to a counselor or psychiatrist isn't
that enough he says matt
you have to understand this here we are
today where i talk against drugs and
psychiatric abuses of electric shocking
people
against their will of drugging children
with them not knowing the effects of
these drugs
do you know what adderall is do you know
what ritalin is do you know
that ritalin is a street drug do you
understand that and then they go back
and forth and it gets pretty heated etc
etc
later on obviously i'd show the video to
you but we can't because it's footage
but what happens to antidepressants all
it does is mask the problem there's ways
of vitamins and through exercise and
various things
i'm not saying that this isn't real
that's not what i'm saying that it's
an alteration of what i am saying so he
goes on talking about i'm just against
drugs
you know we're living in a time today
where i i would be categorized
categorically
if i was a 12 year old kid man i my
teacher mr woods is teaching math if i
saw a butterfly there i'm following the
butterfly and i'm like in a hole then i
see the swimming pool
then i see a tree that's yellow i would
say why is that yellow why are the other
ones green
where's that cat going and i'm lost i'm
going to a whole different place
they would have put me on so much
medication if it was school today
so what are your thoughts about the
approach we're taking with kids
where they'll first say you know i want
to meet with the parents
i got three kids i want to meet with the
parents and then they meet with you and
then they say
you know i'm not saying your kids has
this but i think it's good you go see
this doctor here and they may make some
recommendations because
he's a little bit different than others
and she's a little bit different
and you know who knows maybe medicine
may be the solution so
what are your thoughts about tom
cruise's assessment on
medicine not being the solution to
helping people's psychological issues
i think how psychiatry is currently
practiced is
just a scandal and it's a mess um
85 percent of psychiatric drugs are
prescribed by non-psychiatric physicians
in 10-minute office visits there
are so many other avenues to have a
better brain and a better life
yet if those things don't work
for your depression please give me an
antidepressant
targeted to my brain i mean first look
at my brain
so medicine is not the enemy medicine is
not
of the devil i've seen ritalin
take children from d's and f's days and
bees
one of my daughters who and i missed it
until she was in 10th grade
and i'm one of the world experts on abv
and when i scanned her because she just
kept having problems
she had a really sleepy brain and the
next day on riddling it normalized it
and she went from b's and c's working
her brains out
to straight a's for 10 years
and got into the world's best
veterinarian school
at the university of edinburgh in
scotland
there's no way that would have happened
if i wouldn't have balanced her brain
now my first thought is well let's get
their diet right and then let's see
let's use nutrients natural supplements
and then let's see if it's a family
problem let's get
everybody's brain and the family better
and then let's
see but let's not throw out medicine i
mean what other branch of medicine would
go okay can't use medicine if you use
medicine
you're a bad person that's ridiculous
you know
medicine is there as a tool to help
right for every diabetic
please get your diet right let's do that
first but if you don't i need to put you
on insulin or you're going to die
if you don't treat bipolar disorder if
you don't treat
depression and sometimes patients do
what you want them to do
like i saw someone yesterday she's like
i'm all in i'm gonna do everything you
say
well odds are she will not need medicine
or will need less medicine
other people they don't have the mental
discipline
to do it or the motivation to do it
and for me i think of it as informed
consent
you know my job isn't to tell you what
to do my job is to give you the options
and you choose that's what good doctors
do they don't tell you what to do
they teach you what's going on and then
they give you options
and then you decide and then i get to
supervise whatever you
decide as long as it's reasonable
interesting
um you know do you see a do you see a
a uh i mean a lot of studies comes out
and you see the level of addiction to
some of these drugs
how do we manage that from happening if
there was a way to improve some of the
addiction to these drugs you're somebody
that's been in this for quite a long
time
what would your suggestion be well i
would want to know why they're using
the drug and the hysteria around
stimulants like adderall and ritalin
um my biggest problem with teenagers who
i think need to take them
is they don't take them is they skip
them
they miss them it's not that they take
more
and more to get the same result that's
what addicts
do it's when you dial it in right
they work the problem is is we think of
add as
one thing oh you have add take ritalin
i wrote a book about this called healing
add where
based on our brain imaging work it's
seven different things
please don't give everybody ritalin
because some people like my daughter it
helped
dramatically other people it makes them
suicidal and whenever you use
one treatment fits everybody right it'd
sort of be like you have chest pain
let's give everybody
nitroglycerin well that would be
ridiculous because there's a hundred
different causes of chest pain
and you know you may have been
distracted because you were super smart
and you had all these other ideas come
into your head
or you may be distracted because you
were in a car accident when you were
four years old
and it hurts your frontal lobes we just
need to
look at what we do before we do it uh
doc
for the folks who are in business who
are under a lot of stress what what is a
headache on this side headache on this
side headache on this side headache on
this side when you say my head hurts
is there a difference or it's all a
headache well no
it's just like with add there's ten
different kinds of headaches there's
stress headaches they're migraine
headaches or cluster headaches
we need to know there's gluten headaches
and dairy headaches
you know are you sensitive to something
you're
consuming um my body's very sensitive to
dairy
if if i just completely avoid it my gi
tract is
very happy is there red meat headaches
um no but they're bacon headaches
and they're nitrite uh nitrate headaches
got it um so before we
finalize if you uh uh uh before we wrap
up if you don't mind taking a minute and
telling us about your new book that's
coming out your brain is always
listening what could you tell us about
this book here and obviously the
pressure's on we got to make sure it's
41 weeks
uh uh on new york times but tell us
about your latest book that just came
out today
well i'm super excited your brain is
always listening it's about all the
influences
that are going after your brain moment
by moment and how you can
tame them um the subtitle is tame the
hidden dragons that control
your happiness your habits and your
hangers
and i talk about the dragons from the
past that are always breathing
fire on your emotional brain and how to
tame them that they them and other
dragons
how we're always listening to people
alive and dead
that are still in our head to our habits
to the scheming
dragons uh there's a whole section on
the dragon tamer which is basically how
to activate your frontal lobes to calm
down
your emotional brain and there's a brand
new 12-step program
the anonymous programs like alcoholic
anonymous
those 12 steps were developed 85 years
ago
and there's no neuroscience to them
they're great and i've sent people
and some people have gotten a lot of
benefit and a lot of people have not
gotten any benefit they just couldn't
sort of get into it and i'm like we need
to put neuroscience
in here so there's whole sections uh
steps
on how to get your brain right how to
get cravings under control how to make
good decisions
um and how to repair a damaged brain
because addictions can damage your brain
so it's loaded it's fun
uh i'm really excited about the book
well we're going to put the link below
for the folks that want to get it go
we're going to put the link below to
either amazon or barnes and noble for
you go pick up the book
uh i can i watched a bunch of your
videos and i said you know
what a fascinating mind you have and you
got me thinking about that
stuff that you know i didn't think about
before and i feel i got smarter in the
last hour of spending time with you so
having said that thank you so much
for being a guest with us on
valuetainment for the last
hour or so minus the technical
difficulties
what a joy to be with you thank you for
helping me spread
this word and um if people go to your
brain it's
alwayslistening.com they can get some
special gifts if they order the book
wonderful we will make sure that link is
below
brains right like if you were to
visualize your brain muscle getting
bigger and getting cut up and shredded
what would it look like
i thought it was a very unique
conversation some of the areas you know
you may have agreed with some you may
have not agreed with but i'm curious to
hear your thoughts comment uh below and
if you enjoyed
this interview i did another interview
that was more on the heart side not the
brain
side the heart side who's another very
well-known doctor worldwide if you've
not watched it click here to watch the
interview with that being said thank you
so much for watching everybody take care
bye
[Music]